[Music]
now performing a special Street busing
rendition of Jingle Bells shot right
here at Rockefeller Center give it up
for Lauren dagel
[Applause]
y'all jingle Bell Jingle Bells jingled
all the way oh fun it is to ride in a
one open sleigh jingle bells jingle
bells jingled all the way oh what fun it
is to ride in one open sigh dashing
through the sow and one
open all the F we go laughing all the
ways
on making spirits Bri what fun is to
ride and sing song tonight oh jingle
bells jingle bells jingle all the way
what hard it is to ride in one
open jingle bells jingle bells jingle
all the way what it is to ride in a one
open
jingle bells jingle bells jingle all the
way oh what fun it is to ride in one Us
open sleigh jingle bells jingle bells
jingle all the way oh I it is
to oh what heart it is to ride
yeah oh what it is to ride in one
[Music]
open thank you so much Merry Christmas
y'all thank
you her latest titled album is out now
we'll be right back with what I'm
[Music]
liking
[Applause]
than you guys y'all have a great night
I'm going
home